Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And to explain why we're doing this week's show the way that we're doing it on the subject that we're doing it, I'm joined in the studio by one of our producers, Alex Blumberg. Hello, Alex.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际部，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。为了解释我们为什么会以这种方式制作本周的节目，以及为什么要讨论这个主题，演播室里请来了我们的制作人之一，亚历克斯·布伦伯格。你好，亚历克斯。
Hello, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
Alex.
亚历克斯。
Yes.
在。
What's the reason for this week's show?
本周节目的目的是什么？
Well, I've been thinking about that, and for me, the reason for today's program goes back to a book I read when I was 15 called The Women's Room. Maybe people listening will remember The Women's Room. It was a sort of a seminal feminist novel from the '70s. And I first came across The Women's Room when I was digging through my parents' bookshelves looking for porn, books with naughty parts in them, like Fear of Flying. And so I picked it up, and I read it.
嗯，我一直在思考这个问题。对我来说，今天节目的起因要追溯到我15岁时读的一本书，叫《女性房间》。也许听众们还记得《女性房间》，它是70年代一部具有开创意义的女权主义小说。我第一次接触到这本书是在翻找父母书架寻找色情内容时，也就是那些带有露骨情节的书，比如《飞向恐惧》。于是我拿起它读了起来。
Because the word "women" was in the title?
是因为书名里有“女性”这个词吗？
In lipstick, probably-- or maybe not. Yes.
大概是因为封面是唇膏色吧——或许也不是。是的。
It's incredibly polemical. It describes basically a group of women going from the '50s through the '60s. And they all suffer at the hands of the various men in their lives. And there's constantly-- women are slowly being driven crazy by their husbands' incessant criticism, or they're being called ugly after they get mastectomies, or they're being stifled by their husbands' emotional shallowness. And--
这本书非常有争议。它基本上描述了一群女性从50年代到60年代的经历。她们都在各自生活中的男性手中饱受折磨。书里不断提到——女性因丈夫不断的批评而慢慢变得疯狂，或是在做完乳房切除手术后被说丑陋，又或是因丈夫情感上的浅薄而感到窒息。而且——
And I noticed you happen to have brought into the studio with you today a copy of The Women's Room.
我注意到你今天正好带了一本《女性房间》到演播室。
Yeah, well, I recently reread it just to see. For example, I bookmarked a couple of these things. On page 198, the narrator comes in, and she says, "You think I hate men. I guess I do."
是的，我最近重读了一遍，看看情况如何。比如，我为其中几处做了书签。在第198页，叙述者写道：“你以为我恨男人。我想我是恨的。”
And then a little bit further down, she says, "My feelings about men are the result of my experience. I have little sympathy for them. Like a Jew just released from Dachau, I watch the handsome young Nazi soldier fall writhing to the ground with a bullet in his stomach, and I look briefly and walk on. I don't even need to shrug. I simply don't care." And then a little bit later, "My hatred is learned from experience. That is not prejudice. I wish it were prejudice. Then, perhaps, I could unlearn it." [CHUCKLES] There's not very much pornographic about that.
再往下一点，她说：“我对男人的感受源于我的经历。我一点也不怜悯他们。就像一个刚从达豪集中营释放出来的犹太人，我看着那个英俊的纳粹年轻士兵肚子中弹，在地上痛苦地扭动，我只是看了一眼就走开了。我甚至连耸肩都不需要。我根本不在乎。”稍后又写道：“我的仇恨是从经验中习得的。那不是偏见。我希望那是偏见，那样的话，也许我还能戒掉它。” [笑声] 这其中可没什么色情成分。
It's an incredibly strange thing to read this book at that age because at that age, I felt like, there's one other woman who comes into play at this point, and that's-- I probably shouldn't say her name. Let's just call her Kelly. And she was in eighth grade with me, and she sat two rows away from me.
在那个年纪读这本书感觉非常奇妙，因为当时我感觉，还有另一个女人出现在我的生活中，那就是——我大概不该说出她的名字。我们暂且叫她凯莉吧。她和我同在八年级，坐在离我两排远的地方。
And I remember one time sitting in homeroom with her and seeing her button-down shirt was open a little bit, and I could catch the barest sliver of her little training bra. And it was perhaps the most desire I've ever felt in my life, maybe. I mean, it was just-- it was all-consuming. And I mean, I couldn't concentrate for the rest of the day. I remember it to this day.
我记得有一次坐在自习课上，看到她的衬衫扣子开了点，我看到了她训练文胸的一角。那可能是我这辈子感受到的最强烈的欲望，或许吧。我的意思是，那简直是——让人难以自拔。我那天剩下的时间里完全无法集中注意力。直到今天我都记得那一幕。
And so, at the time I was reading this book, I felt like, oh my god, this is what-- I could see myself becoming the people that she was describing, the men she was describing. And it was really terrifying. My testosterone and how it affects me and how I react to it I think about on a daily basis, all the time. It often feels like there's something in my body giving me instructions that I probably shouldn't follow.
所以，当时我在读那本书时，我心想，天哪，这就是——我能预见自己会变成她笔下的那些人，她笔下的那些男人。这真的很可怕。关于我的睾酮素以及它如何影响我，我如何对它做出反应，我每天都在思考。它总让我觉得身体里有什么东西在给我下指令，而我不该听从。
OK, which brings us to today's program. A while back, Alex tried to convince all of us who work on the radio show that we should do an entire program about testosterone. And I have to say, none of us were really buying it, especially the women, who found the subject dull, even though, as Alex tried to point out to them, women have testosterone, and it affects them pretty much exactly the same way that it affects men. I think all of us were fearing a kind of Men Are from Mars, Women Are from Venus sort of thing, how hormones make men be all aggressive and women all nonaggressive in very stereotyped ways, which all seem kind of reductionistic and dumb-headed.
好的，这引出了今天的节目。不久前，亚历克斯试图说服我们电台的所有人，提议制作一期关于睾酮素的专题节目。我必须说，我们没人买账，尤其是女性同事，她们觉得这个话题很无聊。尽管亚历克斯试图向她们指出，女性体内也有睾酮素，而且它对女性的影响几乎和对男性的影响一模一样。我想我们所有人都担心会演变成那种“男人来自火星，女人来自金星”的套路，即荷尔蒙如何让男人变得攻击性强，让女人变得唯唯诺诺，这种刻板印象看起来既片面又愚蠢。
And then Alex started reading and calling people. And one of the people that he called was this guy who wrote an article for GQ magazine about what happened to him when, because of medical reasons, he stopped producing testosterone. And for four months, he lived without testosterone before they caught the problem. And the way he described living without testosterone was really incredible.
后来亚历克斯开始阅读相关资料并到处联络。他联系的人中有一个男人，他为《GQ》杂志写过一篇文章，讲述了他因为医疗原因停止产生睾酮素后的经历。在查明问题之前，他有四个月是在没有睾酮素的情况下生活的。他描述那种没有睾酮素的生活方式，真的令人难以置信。
Everything that I identify as being me, my ambition, my interest in things, my sense of humor, the inflection in my voice, I mean, the quality of my speech even changed in the time that I was without a lot of the hormone. So, yes, the introduction of testosterone returned everything.
所有我认同为“我”的东西，我的野心、我对事物的兴趣、我的幽默感、我说话的语调，我的意思是，在我缺乏大部分荷尔蒙的那段时间里，我说话的特质甚至都变了。所以，是的，睾酮素的引入让一切都回归了。
There were things that I find offensive about my own personality that were disconnected then, and it was nice to be without them-- envy, the desire to judge itself. I approached people with a humility that I had never displayed before.
那时候，我个性中一些让我反感的特质消失了，没有它们感觉还挺好的——嫉妒，评判他人的欲望。我以一种前所未有的谦卑态度对待他人。
I grew up in a culture, like all of us, that divides the soul from the body, and that that is your singleness, that is your uniqueness. And then I go through this experience where I have small amounts of a bodily chemical removed and then reintroduced, and it changes everything I know as myself. And it violates the sanctity of that understanding. And that's humbling. And it's terrifying.
像我们所有人一样，我在一种将灵魂与肉体分离的文化中长大，认为那是你独特的个体性。然后，我经历了这样一种体验：我身体里少量的化学物质被移除，然后再被重新引入，而这改变了我所认知的一切自我。这违反了那种认知的神圣性。这让人感到卑微，也让人感到恐惧。
I think when it comes to this stuff, most of us do not know what to believe. We're caught between thinking that our hormones and body chemistry can determine so much about our personalities and wanting to believe that they don't. And so, today on our program, we bring you four stories exploring that question-- how much does testosterone determine?
我想在这些问题上，我们大多数人不知道该相信什么。我们在“荷尔蒙和身体化学决定了我们的个性”与“我们不愿相信这一点”之间挣扎。所以，今天在节目中，我们带来四个故事来探讨这个问题——睾酮素到底决定了多少？
Act One of our show, Life at Zero, in which we hear about what it means to lose all your testosterone. Act Two, Infinite Gent-- a woman gets pumped up with several times the testosterone that most men have and describes some surprising changes.
节目的第一幕，生命归零，我们将听到失去所有睾酮素意味着什么。第二幕，无限绅士——一个女性被注入了几倍于常人的睾酮素，并描述了一些令人惊讶的变化。
Act Three, Contest-osterone-- in that act, at Alex's suggestion, all of us on the staff of this radio program decide to find out who has the most and who has the least testosterone with lab tests to see how the levels match with our personality traits, an exercise, I have to say, most of us at this point would not recommend that you try at your workplace or with your friends.
第三幕，睾酮竞赛——在那一幕中，应亚历克斯的建议，我们节目的全体员工决定通过实验室测试来看看谁的睾酮素最多，谁的最少，以此看看结果是否与我们的性格特征相符。我必须说，这是一个我们目前不建议大家在办公室或朋友间尝试的实验。
Act Four, Learning to Shut Up-- in that act, a mother asks her teenage son all her questions about what it means to be a boy, which is, of course, exactly the sort of thing you do not want your mother asking you on tape at 15. Stay with us.
第四幕，学会闭嘴——在那一幕中，一位母亲问了她十几岁的儿子所有关于作为男孩意味着什么的问题，这当然是你在15岁时最不希望你妈妈在录音时问你的那种问题。请继续收听。
Act One, Life at Zero. Testosterone is the hormone of desire. And by that, I don't mean sexual desire. I mean desire, period. In this act, we continue with Alex's interview with that magazine writer from GQ who wrote about his experiences with testosterone anonymously.
第一幕，生命归零。睾酮素是欲望的荷尔蒙。我指的不是性欲，我指的是欲望本身。在这一幕中，我们继续听亚历克斯对那位匿名写下自己睾酮素经历的《GQ》杂志撰稿人的采访。
When you have no testosterone, you have no desire. And when you have no desire, you don't have any content in your mind. You don't think about anything.
当你没有睾酮素时，你就没有欲望。而当你没有欲望时，你的大脑里就没有任何内容。你不会去想任何事情。
And during those months, how were you behaving? What was different?
在那几个月里，你的行为是怎样的？有什么不同？
It wasn't that I was behaving. It was that I was not behaving at all. I was, when I was awake, literally sitting in bed and staring at the wall with neither interest, nor disinterest, for three, four hours at a time. If you'd had a camera in the room, you would have thought I was comatose. I would go out, I would buy some groceries early in the morning, and that would be it. My day had no content. I had no interest in even watching TV, much less reading the newspaper or a book.
并不是我在“表现”什么，而是我根本没有任何行为。醒着的时候，我确实就是坐在床上盯着墙看，既没有兴趣，也没有没兴趣，一坐就是三四个小时。如果你房间里有摄像头，你会以为我昏迷了。我会出门，清晨买点杂货，仅此而已。我的一天没有任何内容。我甚至对看电视没有兴趣，更不用说看报纸或书了。
Food-- I didn't want my food to taste good or interesting. And when you're blessed with that lack of desire, you can eat a loaf of Wonder Bread with mayonnaise. And that will be your day. And I only saw my girlfriend on weekends since she was living in New York and I was living in Philly, so I could get away with it five days at a time. And needless to say, there was absolutely no desire.
食物——我不想让我的食物变得美味或有趣。当你拥有这种缺乏欲望的福气时，你可以吃一条抹了蛋黄酱的普通白面包，那就会是你的一天。由于我女朋友住在纽约，我住在费城，我只有周末才能见到她，所以我可以连续五天这样混过去。不用说，那时候绝对没有任何欲望。
People who are deprived of testosterone don't become Spock-like and incredibly rational. They become nonsensical because they're unable to distinguish between what is and isn't interesting and what is worth noting and what isn't.
缺乏睾酮素的人并不会变得像史波克那样极其理性。他们会变得荒谬，因为他们无法区分什么是感兴趣的，什么不是，什么值得注意，什么不值得。
Describe your thoughts on your morning walk in this state.
描述一下你在那种状态下早晨散步时的想法。
It's very quiet at 5:30, 6:00, 6:30 in the morning. And yeah, and I would see a brick and a wall, and I would think, a brick and a wall. I would see a pigeon and think, a pigeon. It's the most literal possible understanding of the world.
早晨5:30、6:00、6:30的时候非常安静。是的，我会看到一块砖和一面墙，然后心想：一块砖和一面墙。我会看到一只鸽子，然后心想：一只鸽子。这是对世界最字面意义上的理解。
So in this time, when you're without testosterone, you're walking down the street. You're just sort of ticking things off, just making these very simple observations--
所以在没有睾酮素的这段时间，你走在街上。你只是像在打勾一样，做着非常简单的观察——
Like a grocery list.
就像一份购物清单。
Yeah, like a grocery list. Exactly. You also have a thought that comes to you all the time, right?
是的，就像一份购物清单。完全正确。你脑子里还有一个总会出现的想法，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
Talk about that.
说说那个。
Which is a very strange-sounding thing, which is, that is beautiful. Everything I saw, I thought, that is beautiful, which is odd-sounding, I know, because that sounds like the judgment of a person with passion. But it was the exact opposite.
这是一个听起来非常奇怪的想法，那就是：那很美。我看到的一切，我都想：那很美。这听起来很奇怪，我知道，因为这听起来像是充满激情的人的评判。但事实恰恰相反。
It was thought and sometimes even said with complete dispassion, with objectivity. And you see, I was looking at absolutely everything, the most mundane sight in the world-- a weed in the sidewalk-- and thinking, oh, that's beautiful. The surgery scars on people's knees, the bolts in the hubcaps of cars-- all of it. It just seemed to have purpose. And it was like, oh, that's beautiful.
那是完全不动感情、客观地思考，甚至有时说出口的。你看，我在观察绝对一切，世界上最平庸的景象——人行道上的一株杂草——然后心想：哦，那很美。人们膝盖上的手术疤痕，汽车轮毂上的螺栓——所有这些。它似乎都有目的。就像是，哦，那很美。
It's so staggering that that is the core thought that you were left with. Like, if you see things factually, you could have just as easily settled on monstrous or disgusting. And so it's just-- it's interesting to me that the adjective your brain and what was left of your personality chose to ascribe to everything is "beautiful." Why do you think that is?
令人震惊的是，这竟然是你最终留下的核心想法。如果你以事实的角度看事物，你本来可以同样轻易地认为它们是“怪异”或“恶心”的。所以这很有趣，你的大脑和你剩下的个性选择将“美丽”这个形容词赋予了一切。你觉得为什么会这样？
I mean, when I think about that question, the issue of God comes into the equation for me. In a way, being without testosterone brought me closer to God but not in the afternoon-talk-show sense of being-- I don't know-- more humane but actually thinking like God. And of course, I don't mean thinking as God, but I meant thinking like God in an aping, superficial kind of way. He sees things as they really are. He sees you as you really are.
我的意思是，当我思考这个问题时，上帝的问题出现在了我的等式中。在某种程度上，没有睾酮素让我更接近上帝，但不是那种下午脱口秀意义上的——我不知道——更有人情味，而是像上帝一样思考。当然，我不是指像上帝那样思考，我是指以一种模仿的、肤浅的方式像上帝一样思考。他看事物本来的样子。他看你本来的样子。
And I had this omniscient sense, when I was without testosterone, that I was seeing through the skin of things, that I was seeing things as they really were, and that the objective conclusion-- not the judgmental one, but the objective conclusion-- was, they are beautiful. Everything is beautiful, from the bugs to the cracks in the sidewalk, to the faces of other people. And it was automatic. Perhaps to see things objectively is to see them, all of them, as beautiful. But in the most-- you have to understand that the thought was expressed in the most flatline, boring way possible. Oh, yeah, that's beautiful. That's beautiful.
当我没有睾酮素时，我有一种全知的感觉，仿佛我能透过事物的表象，看到它们的本来面目，而客观的结论——不是主观的评判，而是客观的结论——就是：它们很美。一切都很美，从虫子到人行道上的裂缝，再到他人的脸庞。而且那是自动的。也许客观地看待事物就是看到它们——全部都——是美丽的。但你要明白，这个想法是以最平淡、最无聊的方式表达出来的。哦，是啊，那很美。那很美。
You would think that this would be a terrible thing, a terrible state to be in. And for most people, it is. But it was weirdly pleasant. And there is a certain appeal, an impossible appeal, to that Rip Van Winkle existence of being without testosterone. You just have to remember that it doesn't matter if you have nothing if you want nothing. Very tricky to get inside that mindset. In some ways, it's difficult for me to even remember it now, but it had its allure.
你可能认为这会是一件可怕的事情，一种可怕的状态。对于大多数人来说确实如此。但它诡异地令人愉悦。那种没有睾酮素的“李伯大梦”式生存状态有一种特定的吸引力，一种不可能的吸引力。你只需要记住：如果你什么都不想要，那么哪怕你一无所有也无所谓。要进入这种思维定式非常棘手。在某些方面，我现在甚至很难记起那种感觉，但它确实有它的诱惑力。
Well, I can understand that because desire often feels like a burden. It often feels like if I just didn't want that thing, not having it wouldn't be so painful.
嗯，我能理解，因为欲望通常感觉是一种负担。如果你只是不想要那件东西，那么得不到它就不会那么痛苦。
There you go.
就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
All that wanting.
所有的那种渴望。
Act Two, Infinite Gent. Well, we just heard from somebody whose testosterone dropped to nothing. Now we have the story of someone whose level got a huge boost. Griffin Hansbury was born female, but seven years ago, after college, Griffin took action to become a man. Now, he's had top surgery but not bottom. He does not intend to get that. And he told this story of what it was like to experience the massive increase in testosterone that accompanies this change. He talked with our producer, Alex Blumberg. A warning to listeners that they talk about looking at women and wanting sex during this interview.
第二幕，无限绅士。嗯，我们刚刚听了一位睾酮素降至零的人的经历。现在我们来看一个睾酮素水平大幅提升的人的故事。格里芬·汉斯伯里出生时是女性，但在七年前大学毕业后，格里芬决定变性为男性。现在，他做了上半身手术，但没有做下半身手术，也不打算做。他讲述了伴随这一改变而来的睾酮素急剧增加是种什么体验。他与我们的制作人亚历克斯·布伦伯格进行了交流。提醒听众，他们在采访中谈到了注视女性和想要性爱的内容。
I went to Bryn Mawr College, which is a women's college, and chose a women's college because I strongly identified as a woman at the time, as a feminist, and as a dyke. I had my leather biker jacket and my big leather belt and my black T-shirts and my Doc Marten boots, my combat boots. And that felt pretty comfortable for a while.
我上了布林茅尔学院，那是一所女子学院。我选择它是因为当时我强烈地认同自己是女性，是女权主义者，是一个女同性恋。我穿着皮质机车夹克、系着大皮带、穿黑色T恤和马汀博士靴，那种战斗靴。那让我感觉舒适了一阵子。
And then my sophomore year in college, I was lying in bed with my girlfriend. I don't know if we were talking or what it was, and it just sort of hit me like a bolt of lightning, as they say. And I just knew that I had to change my body. And so I started doing the research on it. And the only way to do that was to take testosterone.
然后在大学二年级，我和女朋友躺在床上。我不知道我们当时在聊什么，还是怎么回事，它就像一道闪电击中了我。我当时就知道，我必须改变我的身体。于是我开始研究相关信息。唯一的办法就是服用睾酮素。
My first injection was a pretty large one of 2 cc's of 200-milligram strength depo-testosterone, which is a fairly high amount. Just to give you a sense of how much that is, the average amount of testosterone in an average male body is between 300 and 1,000 nanograms per deciliter of blood. After that shot and after an average shot, my testosterone levels go up to over 2,000 nanograms per deciliter so that I have the testosterone of two high-testosterone men in my body at once.
我的第一次注射剂量相当大，是2毫升200毫克浓度的环戊丙酸睾酮，这是一个相当高的量。为了让你有个概念，普通男性体内的睾酮素平均量在每分升血液300到1000纳克之间。在那次注射之后，我的睾酮素水平上升到每分升超过2000纳克，所以我的身体里同时拥有两个高睾酮素男人的水平。
You have the testosterone of two linebackers.
你拥有两个线卫的睾酮素量。
Exactly.
没错。
Yeah.
是的。
Exactly. That's a lot. That's a lot of T. And what's amazing about it is how instantaneous it is, that it happens within a few days, really. The world just changes.
没错。那很多。那是大量的睾酮。令人惊叹的是它的瞬间性，它确实在几天内就发生了。世界就这么变了。
What were some of the changes that you didn't expect?
有哪些是你没预料到的变化？
[CHUCKLES] The most overwhelming feeling is the incredible increase in libido and change in the way that I perceived women and the way I thought about sex. Before testosterone, I would be riding the subway, which is the traditional hotbed of lust in the city. And I would see a woman on the subway, and I would think, she's attractive. I'd like to meet her. What's that book she's reading? I could talk to her. This is what I would say. There would be a narrative. There would be this stream of language. It would be very verbal.
[笑声] 最让人不知所措的感觉是性欲的难以置信的增长，以及我感知女性和思考性爱方式的改变。在服用睾酮素之前，我会乘地铁，那通常是城市中欲望的温床。我会看到地铁上的一个女性，心想：她很有魅力。我想认识她。她读的那本书是什么？我可以跟她搭话。这便是我会说的话。会有一个叙述，会有语言流。那是很口语化的。
After testosterone, there was no narrative. There was no language whatsoever. It was just I would see a woman who was attractive or not attractive. She might have an attractive quality, nice ankles or something, and the rest of her would be fairly unappealing to me. But that was enough to, basically, just flood my mind with aggressive pornographic images, just one after another. It was like being in a pornographic movie house in my mind. And I couldn't turn it off. I mean, I could not turn it off. Everything I looked at, everything I touched, turned to sex.
在服用睾酮素后，没有了叙述。根本没有任何语言。我只是会看到一个有吸引力或没吸引力的女性。她可能有一个吸引人的特质，比如漂亮的脚踝之类的，而她身体的其他部分对我来说就相当没有吸引力。但这足以让我的脑海中瞬间充斥着攻击性的色情画面，一个接一个。就像我的脑子里在放色情电影。而且我关不掉它。我的意思是，我关不掉它。我看到的一切，触碰的一切，都变成了性。
I was an editorial assistant, and I would be standing at the Xerox machine. And this big, shuddering, warm, inanimate object would just drive me crazy. It was very erotic to me.
我当时是编辑助理，我会站在复印机旁。这个巨大的、颤动的、温暖的、无生命的物体会让我发疯。它对我来说非常色情。
The Xerox machine?
复印机？
The Xerox machine-- or a car. I remember walking up Fifth Avenue one day, and this red convertible went by. It was a Mustang. And I remember just getting this jolt in my pants, this very physical, visceral, sexual reaction to seeing a red convertible.
复印机——或者汽车。我记得有一天走在第五大道上，一辆红色敞篷车开了过去。那是野马车。我记得我的裤裆里有一种冲击，看到红色敞篷车时，这是一种非常生理的、内在的性反应。
What did you do with that? I mean, what did you think?
你对此做了什么？我的意思是，你怎么想？
[CHUCKLES] Well, I felt like a monster a lot of the time. And it made me understand men. It made me understand adolescent boys a lot. Suddenly, hair is sprouting, and I'm turning into this beast. And I would really berate myself for it. I remember walking up Fifth Avenue. There was a woman walking in front of me, and she was wearing this little skirt and this little top. And I was looking at her ass. And I kept saying to myself, don't look at it, don't look at it. And I kept looking at it.
[笑声] 嗯，我很多时候觉得自己像个怪物。这让我理解了男人。这让我理解了青春期的男孩。突然间，毛发长出来了，我变成了这头野兽。我会因此非常责备自己。我记得走在第五大道上。前面有一个女人在走，她穿着短裙和上衣。我在看她的屁股。我不断对自己说：别看它，别看它。但我一直在看它。
And I walked past her, and this voice in my head kept saying, turn around to look at her breasts. Turn around, turn around, turn around. And my feminist female background kept saying, don't you dare, you pig. Don't turn around. And I fought myself for a whole block, and then I turned around and checked her out.
我走过她身边，脑子里的那个声音一直说：转过去看她的胸部。转过去，转过去，转过去。我那女权主义者的女性背景一直在说：你这头猪，别乱来。别转过去。我在那一整条街上都在和自己斗争，最后我还是转过去看了她。
And before, it was cool. When I would do a poetry reading, I would get up, and I would read these poems about women on the street. And I was a butch dyke, and that was very cutting edge. And that was very sexy and raw. And now, I'm just a jerk, you know?
以前，这种感觉很酷。当我去参加诗歌朗诵会时，我会站起来，读那些关于街上女人的诗。我那时是个阳刚的女同性恋，那是很前卫的。那是很性感和原始的。而现在，我只是个混蛋，你知道吗？
[CHUCKLES]
[笑声]
So I do feel like I've lost this edge, this nice avant garde kind of-- and I've gotten into a lot of arguments with women friends, coworkers who did not know about my past as a female. I call myself a post-feminist. And I had a woman say, you're not a post-feminist. You're a misogynist. And I said, that's impossible. I can't be a misogynist. And I couldn't explain to her how I had come to this point in my life. And to her, I was just a misogynist. And that's unfortunate because it's a lot more complicated than that.
所以我确实感觉我已经失去了那种优势，那种很棒的先锋感——而且我和女性朋友、同事发生了很多争论，她们不知道我以前是女性。我称自己为后女权主义者。有个女性对我说：你不是后女权主义者。你是厌女症者。我说：那不可能。我不可能厌女。我无法向她解释我是如何走到今天这一步的。对她来说，我只是个厌女者。这很不幸，因为情况比这复杂得多。
[LAUGHS] I'll say. Wow. Testosterone didn't just turn you into a man. It turned you into Rush Limbaugh.
[笑声] 我想也是。哇。睾酮素不仅把你变成了男人。它还把你变成了拉什·林博。
I know. That I was not expecting. That I was not expecting. So I had to relearn how to talk to women. And I had to learn how to rephrase things, how to hold my tongue on certain things. And I'm not very good at it, so I get in trouble.
我知道。那是我没预料到的。那是我没预料到的。所以我必须重新学习如何与女性交流。我必须学习如何重新组织语言，如何在某些事情上管住自己的舌头。我做得并不好，所以我会惹麻烦。
That is so fascinating that-- because I mean, as a man, I think, from the time I went through puberty, I feel like that's something that I've been learning to do, in a certain way, is just figure out how to say things without getting myself in trouble.
这太令人着迷了——因为作为男人，我想，自从经历青春期以来，我感觉这是我在某种程度上一直学习去做的事情，就是弄清楚如何在不给自己惹麻烦的情况下表达想法。
Right. Yeah, yeah.
没错。是的，是的。
I would not have thought that you would have had that problem.
我没想到你也会遇到这个问题。
Right, because I should know better or something.
对，因为我应该更懂事之类的。
Or something. Are there other ways that you-- other than the visual and other than the libidinal, are there other ways that you feel like testosterone has altered the way you feel or perceive?
或是类似原因。除了视觉和性欲之外，你是否感觉睾酮素还改变了你感受或感知的方式？
Something that happened after I started taking testosterone, I became interested in science. I was never interested in science before.
我开始服用睾酮素后发生的一件事是，我对科学感兴趣了。我以前从来没有对科学感兴趣过。
No way. Come on. Are you serious?
没门。拜托。你是认真的吗？
I'm serious. I'm serious. Now--
我是认真的。我是认真的。现在——
You're just setting us back 100 years, sir.
先生，你这是让我们倒退了100年。
I know I am. I know. I mean, again-- and I have to have this caveat in here-- I cannot say it was the testosterone. All I can say is that this interest happened after T. There's BT and AT, and this was definitely after T. And I became interested in science. I found myself understanding physics in a way I never had before.
我知道我是。我知道。我的意思是，再次声明——我必须加上这个警示——我不能说一定是睾酮素的原因。我只能说这种兴趣是在T之后产生的。有T前和T后，而这绝对是T之后。我对科学产生了兴趣。我发现自己以一种以前从未有过的方式理解了物理学。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It's true. It's true.
这是真的。这是真的。
Wow.
哇。
I did.
我确实理解了。
How about in the way you feel things and in the way you perceive of your feelings? Is there any change there?
那你感受事物的方式，以及感知情感的方式呢？有什么变化吗？
I have a hard time crying. It's very difficult for me to cry. And before testosterone, it was great to, if I was frustrated or angry or sad, have a good cry. You'd feel better afterwards. And I do wonder if there isn't a chemical component behind it because I now have a hard time doing it, and it's very frustrating. And what I will do is when I feel that pressure build up, I'll go into my room, I'll close the door, and force myself-- I have to force myself to cry. And the quality of the crying is different than the quality of the crying was before T. It's very dry. I find myself sort of moaning and sobbing but with very little tears.
我很难哭出来。对我来说哭非常困难。而在睾酮素之前，如果我沮丧、愤怒或悲伤，大哭一场是很好的。之后你会感觉好点。我很怀疑这背后是否有化学成分，因为我现在很难做到这一点，这很令人沮丧。我所做的是，当我觉得压力积聚时，我会走进房间，关上门，强迫自己——我必须强迫自己哭。哭的质量和T之前不一样。非常干涩。我发现自己发出某种呻吟和抽泣，但眼泪很少。
You have answered a lot of questions for us today--
你今天为我们回答了很多问题——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--and reinforced a lot of stereotypes that we've almost dispelled with.
——并强化了许多我们几乎已经消除的刻板印象。
I know.
我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I know I have. I know.
我知道我强化了。我知道。
Did you have an idea of what kind of man you were going to be before the transition?
在变性之前，你对你想成为什么样的男人有什么构想吗？
Yeah.
有的。
This is my model.
这是我的模板。
Yeah.
是的。
Who was it?
是谁？
I used to watch a lot of Beverly Hills 90210, and Jason Priestley was my ideal, at least physically. I mean, I wanted sideburns so bad. And that was the first facial hair that came in. I got these beautiful sideburns. [CHUCKLES] So it was sort of like the James Dean, Jason Priestley kind of model, I think. That didn't quite materialize. I was better at that as a dyke than I am as a man, I have to say.
我过去常看很多《飞越比佛利》，杰森·普里斯特利是我的理想型，至少在外表上。我的意思是，我太想要鬓角了。那是首先长出来的面部毛发。我长出了这些漂亮的鬓角。[笑声] 所以我想，那大概就是詹姆斯·迪恩、杰森·普里斯特利那样的模型。那并没有完全实现。我必须说，作为女同性恋时，我比现在作为男人时更符合那个模型。
[LAUGHS] And how do you feel about it? Is that like sort of a--
[笑声] 你对此感觉如何？这算是一种——
It's a bit of a disappointment. It's a bit of a disappointment. I often ask people, what kind of a guy am I? What do you see? And unfortunately, people often respond that they see a nerd, which I never was before. I was always really kind of cool and popular and hip and whatever.
这有点令人失望。这确实有点让人扫兴。我经常问别人：我是什么样的男人？你看到了什么？不幸的是，人们经常回答说他们看到的是个书呆子，我以前从来都不是那样的。我以前总是真的很酷、很受欢迎、很时髦，不管怎样。
And now, I'm 5 foot 4". And I work out, but I'm not real muscular, and I'm pretty small. I'm pale-skinned, and my hair is starting to thin, and I've got glasses. And of course, I'm also-- I'm the sensitive guy now. I used to be the butch dyke, and I was seen as very aggressive. And I was more masculine, in many ways-- outwardly, anyway-- before testosterone. And now, I don't have to prove anything, so I can lay back and talk with my hands and--
而现在，我身高5英尺4英寸。我健身，但我不是很壮，我很小。我皮肤苍白，头发开始变稀疏，还戴着眼镜。当然，我现在也是——我是那个敏感的男人。我以前是那个阳刚的女同性恋，我被视为非常有攻击性。而且在很多方面——至少在对外表现上——在睾酮素之前，我更男性化。而现在，我不需要证明任何东西，所以我可以躺平，用手势说话——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--all that stuff that you're not supposed to do. So I'm still very much learning how to be a man in the world. There's a lot to learn. Men-- walking the street is a constant battle. It's a constant contest. I began to notice, once I started to pass as a man, that single men walking alone down the street will veer away from their path to walk towards me, get in my space, and then veer back. And it's very much like a aggressive move.
——所有那些你不该做的事情。所以我仍然在学习如何在这个世界上作为一个男人生活。有很多东西要学。男人们——走在街上是一场持续的战斗。这是一种持续的竞赛。我开始注意到，一旦我开始被当作男人看待，单独走在街上的单身男性会偏离他们的路径向我走来，进入我的空间，然后再偏离回去。这很像是一种攻击性的行为。
I've had men, just angry guys walking on the street, just body check me. So I really feel like I have to puff myself up so that people will keep their distance a little bit. But if I'm off guard and I'm walking around and I'm enjoying the scenery, it's pretty much guaranteed that somebody will shove me.
我遇到过一些愤怒的家伙走在街上，直接用身体撞我。所以我真的觉得我必须让自己看起来强壮一些，这样人们才会保持点距离。但如果我没防备，四处闲逛享受风景，几乎可以保证有人会推我。
Were there specific things that you were hoping for?
你当时有没有特别期待的事情？
I think that the main thing that you hope for, that one hopes for, and that I hoped for when starting testosterone, was to pass as male, to be perceived by the world as a man. But I do have a sort of love-hate relationship with passing that my whole deeper self becomes invisible, and my history becomes invisible. And I think that's hard. It's a hard place to be.
我认为你所希望的，一个人所希望的，以及我在开始使用睾酮素时所希望的，主要就是被当作男性，被世界感知为一个男人。但我对这种“通过”有一种又爱又恨的关系，即我整个更深层的自我变得隐形了，我的历史变得隐形了。我认为这很难。这是一个艰难的处境。
Right, right.
对，对。
Especially because when I got my first job as a man, they didn't know anything about my past. It was very corporate. So I had to let go of any edgy clothing and facial hair and whatnot that I had before, and I became really boring. I mean, I felt like, wow, people must think I'm really boring. If they only knew that I'm so fascinating.
尤其是当我作为男人得到第一份工作时，他们对我过去一无所知。那是非常企业化的环境。所以我不得不放弃任何前卫的服装、面部毛发之类的我以前拥有的东西，我变得非常无聊。我的意思是，我感觉，哇，人们一定觉得我很无聊。要是他们知道我其实是多么迷人就好了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Throughout those almost four years, I had to conceal a lot. I would lie about where I went to college because I went to Bryn Mawr, and I couldn't say I went to Bryn Mawr.
在那近四年里，我不得不隐瞒很多东西。我会谎报我大学去哪里，因为我去了布林茅尔学院，而我不能说我去过布林茅尔。
What college did you say you went to?
那你说了哪所大学？
[CHUCKLES] Well, Bryn Mawr is in a bi-college relationship with Haverford College. And so I would say I went to Haverford, which is kind of-- I don't want to say anything bad about Haverford. Some of my best friends went there. But I think Bryn Mawr is a superior school to Haverford. I do. And I think it's a superior education. And when I have to say I went to Haverford, it's like a little knife in my heart.
[笑声] 嗯，布林茅尔学院和哈弗福德学院有双校关系。所以我常说我去了哈弗福德，这有点——我不想对哈弗福德说任何坏话。我最好的朋友有一些去了那里。但我认为布林茅尔是比哈弗福德更好的学校。我确实这么认为。我认为那是一种更优越的教育。当我不得不说我去了哈弗福德时，那就像我心里插了一把小刀。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
But [CHUCKLES] no offense to my Haverford friends.
但是 [笑声] 对我的哈弗福德朋友们无意冒犯。
What do you feel like the biggest thing that you do miss is?
你觉得你最怀念的是什么？
Hmm. Maybe the close relationships that I had with women. I still have close relationships with the women I've known since before T, but I don't make close relationships with new female friends. It's hard. It's hard to do. There's a barrier. So I kind of miss being part of a cool bunch of women. I actually like women better than men. It just so happens that I fit in more as a man. But I think women are really cool. Sisterhood is powerful-- all that stuff, so--
嗯。也许是我和女性之间曾经拥有的亲密关系。我和在T之前就认识的女性仍然保持着亲密关系，但我不会和新的女性朋友建立亲密关系。这很难。很难做到。有一道屏障。所以我有点怀念曾经作为一群很酷的女性中的一员。其实我比男人更喜欢女人。只是刚好我作为男人更合群。但我认为女性真的很酷。姐妹情谊是强大的——所有那些，所以——
[CHUCKLES] Yeah, yeah. And what do you think is the biggest thing you've gained?
[笑声] 是的，是的。你觉得你获得的最大收获是什么？
Biggest thing I've gained-- it's just so great when people call me sir, even after seven years. I don't always hear it, but it still rings a little bell inside my heart, like, oh, sir. It's wonderful. And it's something that when I was a little kid, I used to wish for. And turn me into a boy-- Pinocchio.
获得的最大收获——当人们称呼我为“先生”时，感觉真是太棒了，即使是七年后。我并不总能听到，但它仍然会在我心中敲响一个小钟，就像，哦，先生。那真是太美妙了。这是我小时候曾祈祷过的事情。把我变成男孩——匹诺曹。
And you never really think it's possible. But it is possible. And the other nice thing about it is knowing that that's possible, that you can actually make this enormous leap, means that, well, then anything else must be possible, too, because this is certainly unbelievable.
你从没真的认为那是可能的。但它是可能的。而且关于这一点的另一件好事是，知道了这是可能的，知道了你可以做出这个巨大的飞跃，意味着，嗯，那么其他任何事情也一定是可能的，因为这无疑是令人难以置信的。
Griffin Hansbury lives in New York. He talked with our producer, Alex Blumberg. Griffin is near completion on a memoir about his own experience transitioning from female to male. He's looking for a publisher.
格里芬·汉斯伯里住在纽约。他与我们的制作人亚历克斯·布伦伯格进行了交流。格里芬正在完成一本关于他自己从女性转变为男性的经历的回忆录。他正在寻找出版商。
What occurs to me is that you're in a perfect position to offer romantic advice to anybody who needs it.
我想说的是，你处于一个完美的地位，可以为任何需要的人提供浪漫建议。
I know, I know. And I have a friend with a website, and we've been dying to do an online advice column called "Ask a Guy Who Used to Be a Girl."
我知道，我知道。我有一个朋友有个网站，我们一直渴望开一个在线咨询专栏，叫“问一个曾经是女孩的男人”。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
We haven't gotten it off the ground yet.
我们还没把它搞起来。
You would make a million dollars.
你会赚到一百万。
Coming up, who has the most testosterone-- the slightly femme-y host of a public radio program, his staff, or a gay man in New York City? Answer in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，谁拥有最多的睾酮素——是一个公共广播节目的稍显女性化的主持人，他的员工，还是纽约市的一个同性恋男人？一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际部为您揭晓答案。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, testosterone, and just how much does it determine of our personalities and fates? Well, we've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Contest-osterone.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同的故事。今天的节目是关于睾酮素的，它对我们的个性和命运到底决定了多少？好吧，我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，睾酮竞赛。
At some point in putting together this week's radio show, Alex, who you heard a lot of in the first half of our program, suggested that it might be a fun thing to do and might illustrate some interesting principles about testosterone if everybody on the radio staff would get their testosterone level checked. We could each predict who would come out as number one, number two, and so forth, based on their personalities. And then we would compare the results with what each of us had predicted.
在制作本周广播节目的某个时候，你在前半部分节目中听过很多的亚历克斯，建议说，如果电台的每个人都去检查他们的睾酮素水平，那可能会是一件有趣的事情，而且可能阐明一些关于睾酮素的有趣原则。我们可以每个人预测谁会是第一名，谁是第二名等等，基于他们的个性。然后我们将结果与我们每个人的预测进行比较。
Since men always have a lot more testosterone than women, we would do two rankings-- one for the men, one for the women. We invited two of our regular contributors, David Rakoff and Sarah Vowell, to take part with us, making it five men and four women in all.
由于男性体内的睾酮素总是比女性多得多，我们将进行两次排名——男性一次，女性一次。我们邀请了我们两位常驻撰稿人大卫·拉科夫和萨拉·沃威尔参与其中，总共五名男性和四名女性。
It turns out to be remarkably easy to get your testosterone assessed. You spit into a little tube twice a day and send it to a lab-- in our case, the Yerkes National Primate Research Center. And I think it was Jonathan and Starlee, producers on our show who you sometimes hear during stories on the air, who pointed out first that the entire enterprise might not be such a good idea.
事实证明，获得睾酮素评估非常容易。每天吐两次唾液进小管子，然后寄给实验室——在我们的案例中是耶基斯国家灵长类动物研究中心。我认为是乔纳森和斯塔莉，我们节目的制作人，你有时会在节目故事中听到他们，他们首先指出，整个企业可能不是一个好主意。
I just think we're opening a whole can of worms here that we don't want to be doing.
我只是觉得我们在这里开启了一个我们不想招惹的麻烦。
It's all very-- well, this whole thing's kind of a mess, diplomatic-wise.
这一切都很——好吧，从外交角度看，这一切都是一团糟。
How so?
怎么说？
Like, I mean, either we'll walk away from this finding out that Starlee has more testosterone than I do, and she'll end up being incredibly upset, and I'll be upset, and everyone will just be upset. I mean, what do we hope to gain, really, from all of this? This whole thing is going to lead to heartbreak, somehow.
我的意思是，要么我们会发现斯塔莉的睾酮素比我的多，她会因此变得极其沮丧，我也会沮丧，每个人都会很沮丧。我的意思是，从这一切中我们到底能得到什么？这一切最终都会导致心碎，以某种方式。
I've been thinking a lot about it, and I can't really decide whether I want to have more or if I want to have less.
我一直在思考它，我真的无法决定我是想拥有更多还是更少。
This is Wendy, another producer.
这是温迪，另一位制作人。
I don't know. Having more makes me seem like an [BLEEP]-hole.
我不知道。拥有更多让我看起来像个混蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And having not enough makes me seem like a pushover, sucker.
而拥有不够多让我看起来像个好欺负的软蛋。
For the men, I think it'll be a big deal.
对于男人来说，我觉得这会是一件大事。
This is Julie, the senior producer of our program.
这是朱莉，我们节目的高级制作人。
I think it'll change all your interactions with each other. You'll know, when you're talking to each other, who beat you. I think it'll change everything.
我认为这会改变你们所有人之间的互动。当你们彼此交谈时，你会知道谁赢了你。我觉得这会改变一切。
Nonetheless, we marched toward the abyss. To find out what personality traits actually correlate with high testosterone and low testosterone, we checked with somebody who's done a lot of research on the subject, James Dabbs of Georgia State University, author of a book called Heroes, Rogues, and Lovers-- Testosterone and Behavior.
尽管如此，我们还是走向了深渊。为了找出哪些个性特征真正与高睾酮素和低睾酮素相关，我们咨询了一位在该领域做过大量研究的人——乔治亚州立大学的詹姆斯·达布斯，他是《英雄、流氓和情人——睾酮素与行为》一书的作者。
The most simple thing, I would say, is it leads to a certain boldness and fearlessness and confidence in a person's behavior. They tend to focus upon what they do, move forward with less conflict. The downside is they don't pay attention to things going on around them, so they get blindsided by accidents and other things going on.
最简单的话来说，它导致了某种大胆、无畏和自信的行为。他们倾向于专注于他们所做的事情，向前迈进，冲突较少。缺点是他们不注意周围发生的事情，所以会被意外和其他发生的事情弄得措手不及。
What are some of the misconceptions you run into?
你遇到过哪些误解？
Well, they think it makes them manly and heroic and virile and sexual, which is not really true. It doesn't take much testosterone to have sex. So I mean, that's beside the point.
嗯，他们认为这使他们变得男人、英雄、阳刚和性欲强，这并不是真的。拥有性并不需要多少睾酮素。所以，我的意思是，那离题了。
What scientific studies can tell us is that, in general, more testosterone does not mean you're a more successful person. In fact, blue-collar workers tend to have more testosterone than white-collar workers, and unemployed men have more than either group.
科学研究告诉我们的是，通常情况下，睾酮素多并不意味着你是一个更成功的人。事实上，蓝领工人的睾酮素往往比白领工人多，而失业男性的睾酮素比这两组人都要多。
Actors and trial lawyers-- people who basically go on stage, in one way or another-- tend to have very high testosterone levels. Higher testosterone correlates with baldness and with bigger muscles. And researchers say that people with lots of testosterone have a wolfish smile. And people with less testosterone have a kinder smile, and they smile more often, as if to say, don't hurt me.
演员和出庭律师——那些基本上以某种方式登上舞台的人——往往有非常高的睾酮素水平。高睾酮素与秃顶和更大的肌肉有关。研究人员说，睾酮素水平高的人有一种狼性的微笑。而睾酮素水平低的人有一种更友善的微笑，他们笑得更频繁，仿佛在说：别伤害我。
Testosterone goes up when you score a victory at something. It goes down when you suffer a defeat. In one study of World Cup soccer fans watching a match on television, testosterone dropped in fans of the losing team and rose in the fans of the winning team.
当你在一件事上取得胜利时，睾酮素水平会上升。当你遭受失败时，它会下降。在一项针对在电视上观看比赛的世界杯足球迷的研究中，失败方的球迷睾酮素水平下降，而获胜方的球迷睾酮素水平上升。
For people, there's not a lot of difference between being in the contest and watching the contest. We can empathize with it so well.
对于人类来说，参与竞赛和观看竞赛之间没有太大的区别。我们能很好地对它产生共鸣。
So what would all this mean for our radio staff? Well, when it came to predicting which of the women would have the highest testosterone, there was a clear majority in the voting. Here are Sarah Vowell, Todd, our production manager, and Wendy weighing in.
那么这对我们的电台员工意味着什么呢？好吧，当预测哪个女性会有最高的睾酮素时，投票中出现了绝对多数。这是萨拉·沃威尔，我们的生产经理托德，以及温迪的看法。
Julie will win.
朱莉会赢。
Julie's tough. She can certainly push me around sometimes.
朱莉很硬。她有时候确实能对我推三阻四。
I think Julie has the most because she is the boldest of all of us, right? She says the boldest things.
我觉得朱莉最高，因为她是我们在座中最胆大的，对吧？她说的最胆大。
When we're all together in the same place, it is clearly Julie who is the alpha of the whole group. Though, at some point in putting together this week's radio show, Alex and Julie sat down in a studio, and he asked her to predict which women would have the highest testosterone. And here's how she lined it up.
当我们都在同一个地方时，显然朱莉是整个群体的头领。虽然，在制作本周广播节目的某个时候，亚历克斯和朱莉坐在演播室里，他让她预测哪个女性会有最高的睾酮素。这是她安排的顺序。
Wendy first, and then Starlee, and then Sarah, I guess.
温迪第一，然后是斯塔莉，然后是萨拉，我想。
And then?
然后呢？
And then me, just passive me--
然后是我，仅仅是消极的我——
Yeah.
是的。
--just taking it easy. Girly, girly me--
——只是放轻松。娘娘腔的我——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--just being feminine over here in the corner. Honestly, who do I think?
——只是作为一个女性在角落里。老实说，我觉得谁最高？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I fear me.
嗯，我怕我自己。
What do you think it would mean if you won?
你觉得如果你赢了意味着什么？
Well, then it would confirm all my worst suspicions about myself, that I'm really aggressive and pushy and a hothead. I fear me.
嗯，那将证实我对自己最坏的猜想，即我真的很激进、爱管闲事、是个暴脾气。我怕我自己。
Among the men, there was no favorite. You could make an argument for any of the men on the staff. Todd likes sports, and he isn't such a bookworm softy, like the rest of us on the staff. Alex plays a lot of sports, and he gets into fights on the basketball court. Jonathan is balding, and he has a lot of muscle-- corresponds with testosterone. I host a national radio show, which must count for something, right? But when we sat down to talk about it, it wasn't really clear exactly what else should be taken into account. Here's Jonathan.
在男性中，没有热门人选。你可以为员工中的任何一个男性找理由。托德喜欢运动，他不是像我们其他员工那样的书呆子。亚历克斯喜欢很多运动，他在篮球场上会打架。乔纳森正在秃顶，而且他有很多肌肉——这与睾酮素相符。我主持一个全国性的广播节目，这肯定得算点什么，对吧？但当我们坐下来讨论它时，并不清楚到底还有什么应该被考虑进去。这是乔纳森。
I don't entirely understand how this whole testosterone thing works. It's like, who can yell the loudest, right? Who has the most rage? I have rage. I mean, unfortunately, it's like impotent rage. And I don't know how that's going to rank.
我不太明白整个睾酮素是怎么运作的。就像，谁能喊得最响，对吧？谁有最多的愤怒？我有愤怒。我的意思是，不幸的是，那是像阳痿般的愤怒。我不知道这会如何排名。
And then, if the main thing the testosterone corresponds with is decisiveness, how does that swing the whole rating?
而且，如果睾酮素主要对应的东西是决断力，那这会如何影响整个评级？
I didn't realize that the whole decision-making thing came into--
我没意识到整个决策的事项会进入——
Is it making you--
是在让你——
--this whole testosterone thing. Yeah, it's making it--
——整个睾酮素这件事中。是的，这让它变得——
--reevaluate?
——重新评估？
--complicated. Yeah, because I mean, I'm just filled with regret.
——复杂。是的，因为我的意思是，我充满了后悔。
Again, Julie-- quick decisions, doesn't look back.
再次强调，朱莉——快速决策，从不回头。
That's very true.
那确实是真的。
Doesn't look back, I know. Same with Sarah.
不回头，我知道。萨拉也一样。
I look back like I'm looking--
我回头看就像我在看——
I look back pretty much every single--
我几乎每一天每一秒都在回头看——
Every single second of the day.
每一天的每一秒。
Every single.
每一秒。
Every single. I'm regretting what I'm saying right now.
每一秒。我现在就在后悔刚才说的话。
Me, too. Yeah. I'm always filled with regret.
我也是。是的。我总是充满了后悔。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You're regretting it even as you're saying it?
你甚至在说话的时候就在后悔？
Even as-- even now. Even now. Even now.
甚至在——甚至现在。甚至现在。甚至现在。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then there's the question of David Rakoff. He's gay and a fan of Martha Stewart. But he's also balding, and he's worked as a professional actor, which both correspond with high testosterone levels. So how do you figure that one out?
然后就是大卫·拉科夫的问题。他是同性恋，是玛莎·斯图尔特的粉丝。但他也在秃顶，他曾做过职业演员，这两者都对应着高睾酮素水平。那你怎么算这个呢？
The one thing I do worry about the testosterone is Alex told me, when I did my spit, that I had to have some Extra spearmint gum to activate my salivary glands. But the only thing that I could find was Extra Polar Ice, which has flavor crystals. And I worry that my sample might have flavor crystals in it.
我唯一担心的睾酮素问题是亚历克斯告诉我的，当我吐口水时，我必须吃一些Extra薄荷口香糖来激活唾液腺。但我能找到的只有Extra极地冰，里面有调味晶体。我担心我的样本里可能有调味晶体。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So in fact, I might just simply be the most refreshing.
所以事实上，我可能只是最清新的那个。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
One notable difference between the men and the women, although none of the women wanted to have much testosterone, Alex, Todd, and I very, very much wanted to win. Jonathan claimed he did not want to win, but none of us believe him. And Rakoff also said that he had no interest in winning at all but then proceeded immediately-- I mean immediately-- to talk smack about his opponents in a very competitive way. And that was the state of things when we got our results from the lab just two days ago.
男性和女性之间的一个显著差异是，尽管女性都不想拥有太多睾酮素，亚历克斯、托德和我非常、非常想赢。乔纳森声称他不想赢，但我们谁也不信。而且拉科夫也说他对赢一点兴趣都没有，但随后立即——我的意思是立即——以一种非常有竞争力的态度对他对手说坏话。当我们两天前从实验室拿到结果时，情况就是这样。
All right, well, it is two days before our broadcast day as I record this. Our entire staff is on mic, plus contributors David Rakoff and Sarah Vowell in New York. Hello, all.
好吧，在我录制这段话时，距离广播日还有两天。我们全体员工都在麦克风前，加上纽约的撰稿人大卫·拉科夫和萨拉·沃威尔。大家好。
Hi.
嗨。
And now, for the results. I am opening the envelope.
现在，公布结果。我正在拆信封。
Wow, that's fascinating.
哇，那真是太迷人了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wow, that's just incredible. OK, among the men, Rakoff is number one and has twice the amount of testosterone of anybody in the group.
哇，那简直难以置信。好吧，在男性中，拉科夫是第一名，而且睾酮素含量是小组中任何人的两倍。
[LAUGHTER, CHEERING]
[笑声，欢呼]
Wow.
哇。
This can't be--
这不可能——
I told you.
我告诉过你。
--correlation with baldness.
——与秃顶相关。
I voted for you, Rakoff.
我投票给了你，拉科夫。
Oh, everybody's trying to get in with him now that he's number one.
哦，每个人都想在拉科夫成为第一名后和他搞好关系。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Then in order, the men are-- it's Rakoff, then Alex at number two, then me, like a point behind you, Alex, then Jonathan, and then Todd, all very closely grouped together.
然后按顺序，男性是——拉科夫，然后是亚历克斯排第二，然后是我，像比你落后一分，亚历克斯，然后是乔纳森，最后是托德，所有人分组非常紧凑。
Wow. But Rakoff has twice as much.
哇。但拉科夫有两倍之多。
As any of us-- the gay Canadian Jew living in Manhattan.
比我们任何人都多——住在曼哈顿的加拿大犹太同性恋者。
OK, we really have to dispense with the Canadian. Actually, that is noncorollary. Believe me.
好吧，我们真的得免去“加拿大”这个标签。事实上，那不是推论。相信我。
What are the numbers exactly? What is it for-- what's Rakoff?
确切的数字是什么？对于——拉科夫是多少？
Rakoff is 274. You're 144. I'm 104--
拉科夫是274。你是144。我是104——
Oh my god.
天哪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh my god.
天哪。
When I looked at the women's results in the envelope, even though she is seven months pregnant, Julie was on top, as we all suspected.
当我看向信封里的女性结果时，尽管朱莉怀孕七个月了，她还是排在榜首，正如我们所怀疑的那样。
That's hard. That's hard. It makes me feel really bossy and aggressive. Now, did they say that the pregnancy would affect it at all?
那很难。那很难。这让我觉得自己真的很霸道、很有侵略性。现在，他们有没有说怀孕会影响它？
Alex, you talked--
亚历克斯，你谈到了——
She says, trying to make sure you get in that whole girly pregnancy thing.
她说，试图确保你在这个整个女性怀孕的事情上占据上风。
Yeah, the fact that I'm able to bear children, the greatest gift a woman can have.
是的，事实上我能够孕育孩子，这是女性能拥有的最伟大的礼物。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have to say, Wendy and Todd, the lowest-scoring woman and man on the staff, really did not seem very happy about this whole thing by the end. Todd, like most of the men on the staff, had never been seen as especially manly during his life. But he thought maybe here, maybe here in this group, compared to the rest of us, he might at least stand a chance.
我必须说，温迪和托德，员工中得分最低的女性和男性，到最后看起来确实对这件事不太高兴。托德，像大多数电台员工中的男人一样，一生中从未被视为特别阳刚。但他认为也许在这里，也许在这个小组里，与其他我们相比，他至少会有机会。
Someone would be girlier than I. If I can't be the most manly in public radio, where the hell can I be the most manly? I kind of wish this was SportsCenter because then I'd be OK. Out of all my fellow staff members at SportsCenter, OK, I could be the one with the least testosterone. But in public radio--
有人会比我更女性化。如果我不能成为公共广播里最阳刚的，那我在哪里能成为最阳刚的？我有点希望这是SportsCenter，因为那样我就没问题了。在我SportsCenter的所有同事中，好吧，我可以是睾酮素最少的一个。但在公共广播里——
We should get them to spit. Is it a real place, SportsCenter? Is that a thing?
我们应该让他们吐口水。SportsCenter是个真实的地方吗？那是个东西吗？
Now, see, that's not fair. How can he have the most testosterone and not know what SportsCenter is? I know what SportsCenter is.
瞧，那不公平。他怎么能拥有最多的睾酮素却不知道SportsCenter是什么？我知道SportsCenter是什么。
The people on our staff who scored low are feeling rather-- they're feeling terrible about it.
我们员工中得分低的那些人感到相当——他们对此感觉糟糕透了。
I know them.
我认识他们。
What should I say to them?
我该对他们说什么？
I hated to measure them. I just knew that would happen. It always happens. I told them that. [LAUGHS] Well, they are what they are. Are they in any way different?
我恨测量他们。我早就知道会发生这种情况。总是这样。[笑声] 嗯，他们就是他们。他们有什么不同吗？
After our test, James Dabbs reminded me that it was important to remember that any individual person might not conform to the stereotypes of who has higher testosterone. It's not the final answer as to what you're like.
我们的测试后，詹姆斯·达布斯提醒我，重要的是要记住，任何个体都可能不符合谁拥有更高睾酮素的刻板印象。这不是你是什么样的人的最终答案。
I tested a stuntman in a movie set once, and he came out low in testosterone and was terribly unhappy about being low in testosterone. The fact is he still was a stuntman and did all the work that other people couldn't do, so he shouldn't have been focusing upon that testosterone. I think to focus upon the testosterone is the wrong thing to do.
我曾经在电影片场测试过一个特技演员，他的睾酮素测试结果很低，而且对自己睾酮素低感到非常不高兴。事实是，他仍然是一名特技演员，做了其他人无法完成的所有工作，所以他不应该把注意力集中在那个睾酮素上。我认为专注于睾酮素是错误的做法。
Now, when you tried to convince him that he shouldn't feel bad about it, did he find that persuasive at all?
现在，当你试图说服他不要因此感到糟糕时，他觉得有说服力吗？
No. No, he was just unhappy.
不。不，他只是不高兴。
Act Four, Learning to Shut Up. So we thought we would end today's program the same way we began-- with the story of a 15-year-old boy. We had this story about one with his mom's questions about his maleness, as his body floods with adolescent hormones. His mom, Miriam Toews, tells the story.
第四幕，学会闭嘴。所以我们想以我们开始今天节目的方式结束节目——和一个15岁男孩的故事。我们有这个故事，关于一个男孩和他妈妈关于他男性特质的问题，当时他正处于青春期荷尔蒙泛滥的阶段。他的妈妈，米里亚姆·托斯，讲述了这个故事。
First off, his hair is red and shaggy and longish, and he's pale and slim and 6 feet tall. Music is everything to him, which makes sense because he's 15. I was 22 when he was born. I'd never had brothers or any close male relatives, and I'd always dreamed of having a brother or a son. The idea of having a boy in my family was strange and exotic.
首先，他的头发是红色的，蓬乱且有点长，他脸色苍白，身材苗条，身高6英尺。音乐对他来说就是一切，这很合理，因为他才15岁。他出生时我22岁。我从未有过兄弟或任何亲密的男性亲戚，我一直梦想有一个兄弟或儿子。家里有一个男孩的想法是陌生而新奇的。
When he was born, it was like I had given birth to a llama or something. All my girlfriends came to visit me and him in the hospital. And I took them down to the second floor nursery, and we stared at him in awe from behind a glass window. That's him, I said, with the orange fuzz on his head. He was lying naked and spread-eagled under a bright heat lamp. He seemed very content.
他出生时，就像我生了一头羊驼之类的。我所有的女朋友都来医院看我和他。我带她们去二楼的育婴室，我们透过玻璃窗惊叹地看着他。就是他，我说，头上长着橙色绒毛的那个。他赤身裸体，在明亮的加热灯下四肢摊开地躺着。他看起来很满足。
My friend, Carol, gasped and said, oh my god, he's got the biggest balls I've ever seen in my life. We all started laughing our heads off. And then the nurse came and told us his scrotum would shrink to normal size in a few days. I haven't seen him naked in years, but it still often feels, when I look at him, that I'm gazing at an odd creature from behind a glass.
我的朋友卡罗尔倒吸一口凉气说：天哪，他有我这辈子见过最大的蛋蛋。我们所有人都笑得前仰后合。然后护士过来告诉我们，他的阴囊几天内就会缩回到正常大小。我已经多年没见过他赤身裸体了，但当我看着他时，依然经常觉得是在透过玻璃看着一个奇怪的生物。
So, do you think about girls?
那么，你想过女孩吗？
Yes.
想过。
And what do you think about them?
你对她们怎么看？
I don't know. Some of them are cool.
不知道。她们中有些很酷。
Yeah? So, what makes them cool?
是吗？那么，是什么让她们酷？
I don't know.
不知道。
All his life, Owen's been a quiet kid-- not sullen but just rather silent. When he was a baby and I'd be pushing him around in his stroller, people would stop and crouch down and talk to him and expect him to laugh and smile. And all he'd do was sigh and stare at them.
欧文从小就是一个安静的孩子——不是阴郁，而是相当沉默。当他还是婴儿时，我推着他的婴儿车，人们会停下来蹲下和他说话，指望他笑。他只会叹气，盯着他们看。
When he got a little older and went over to his friends' places to play and it was time for him to go home, he just got up and walked right out the door to the car. He didn't say, hey, thanks for having me, or next time, we'll play at my place, or even goodbye. We'd be driving home, and I'd be trying to explain to him that it seemed rude, and that sometimes, we just had to say certain things at certain times. It was polite and expected. He'd just sigh and nod and kick the dash or stick his head entirely out the window.
当他大一点，去朋友家玩，该回家的时候，他只是站起来就直接走出门上车。他不说什么“嘿，谢谢你们邀请我”或“下次来我家玩”或甚至“再见”。我们在开车回家的路上，我试图向他解释这似乎很粗鲁，有时我们必须在特定时间说特定的话。这是礼貌且被期待的。他只会叹气、点头、踢仪表板，或把头完全伸出窗外。
But back then, I could figure out what was going on in his head, even if he didn't come right out and say it, like when he was three, and he didn't want me to go out. Instead of grabbing my leg or having a tantrum or something, he'd hide my shoes and then sit on the couch, pretending to read the newspaper, while I searched all over the place.
但那时，我能猜出他脑子里在想什么，即使他没有直接说出来，比如当他三岁时，他不希望我出去。他不是抱住我的腿或发脾气之类的，他会把我的鞋藏起来，然后坐在沙发上，假装看报纸，而我到处找。
When he was eight and angry and sitting in a tree and throwing stones at the car or something, I'd go outside, knowing it would be a matter of minutes before he'd start to cry and then slowly spill his guts about whatever series of events it was that led to his meltdown and that the whole scene would end with hugs and apologies and probably a large muscle activity, like him cheerfully taking shots at my head with a soccer ball. Now, though, the signs are harder, if not impossible, to read. I'm not sure there are any, actually. And I have no idea where to begin my search.
当他八岁，愤怒地坐在树上，往车上扔石头什么的，我会走出去，知道只需几分钟，他就会开始哭，然后慢慢把憋在心里的事倾倒出来，关于导致他崩溃的一系列事件，整个场景会以拥抱和道歉结束，可能还会有一项大型肌肉活动，比如他愉快地用足球向我的头射门。但现在，这些迹象更难读懂了，如果不是不可能的话。我不确定实际上还有没有迹象。我也不知道从哪里开始搜索。
What do you think girls think about you when they think about you?
你觉得女孩们想到你时，会怎么想？
I don't know. Nothing.
不知道。什么都不会想。
You think no girl ever thinks anything about you?
你觉得从没女孩对你有任何想法吗？
Maybe. I don't know.
也许吧。不知道。
He brought 85 CDs with him for a family road trip that would last 11 days. He also brought his sketchbook, which started out as an art class project and has since evolved into a kind of diary, I think. He tends to write things down like, "Jesus, I got to find someone irrational," or, "The [BLEEP] I'm passing off as writing is slowly killing me."
他为一次长达11天的家庭公路旅行带了85张CD。他还带了他的素描本，那最初是一个美术课作业，后来演变成了一种日记，我想。他倾向于写下诸如：“天哪，我得找个非理性的人，”或，“我当作写作的垃圾正在慢慢杀死我。”
The first day of our road trip through North Dakota to South, the music war started. His 12-year-old sister, Georgia, claimed the very back seat of the minivan and was content to lie there, surrounded by nail polish and beads and thread and Hershey Kisses and Archie comics, and listen to her music on her Discman, mostly R&B stuff, Destiny's Child and the Save the Last Dance soundtrack.
我们穿越北达科他州到南达科他州的公路旅行的第一天，音乐战争就开始了。他12岁的妹妹乔治亚占领了小型货车的最后一排，满足地躺在那里，被指甲油、珠子、线、好时之吻巧克力和阿奇漫画包围，用她的随身听听音乐，大部分是R&B，比如真命天女和《留住最后一支舞》的原声带。
My husband, Cassidy, and I sat in the front, and Owen sat on the seat right behind us so he could listen to his CDs on the stereo. We tell him to listen to them on his Discman, which he did sometimes, but then he'd miss out on our sporadic conversations, which he enjoyed either participating in or mocking.
我丈夫卡西迪和我坐在前排，欧文坐在我们身后的座位上，这样他就可以在音响上听他的CD。我们告诉他用随身听听，他有时会照做，但那样他就会错过我们偶尔的对话，他要么喜欢参与，要么喜欢嘲弄。
Sometimes he'd give us a choice of his CDs to play. Nirvana, he'd say. You guys like Nirvana, right? Yeah, but the unplugged one, we'd say. Oh, Lord, help me now, he'd say. He'd pop a dozen CDs into the player-- They Will Know Us by the Trail of Dead, Black Rebel Motorcycle Club, At the Drive-In, other stuff. And we'd listen to half a song from each one and go, nope, nope, nope.
有时他会给我们选几张他的CD放。“涅槃乐队，”他说。“你们喜欢涅槃，对吧？”“是的，但不插电的那张，”我们说。“哦，主啊，帮帮我吧，”他说。他会在播放器里塞进十几张CD——比如《他们会通过死人之踪认出我们》、《黑色叛逆摩托车俱乐部》、《在驾驶座上》，以及其他东西。我们每张听半首歌，然后说：不，不，不。
I had wanted to learn more about him from his music. I was pretty sure his lyrics would tell me more about him than he would. But the problem was I couldn't understand most of the lyrics, and none of his CDs, which he'd bootlegged, had liner notes. We asked him if he didn't miss having liner notes, and he said, man, liner notes. You guys have this unnatural relationship with your liner notes.
我曾想通过他的音乐更多地了解他。我敢肯定他的歌词会比他本人告诉我更多关于他的事。但问题是我听不懂大部分歌词，他盗版的CD也没歌词本。我们问他是否不怀念歌词本，他说：“天哪，歌词本。你们对你们的歌词本有一种不自然的关系。”
What are some of your favorite lyrics?
你最喜欢的一些歌词是什么？
Mm. I like some of the lyrics from the Pixies.
嗯。我喜欢小精灵乐队的一些歌词。
Can you say some of the lyrics from the Pixies?
你能说出一些小精灵乐队的歌词吗？
"You're so pretty when you're unfaithful to me."
“当你对我背叛时，你真漂亮。”
So, what does that mean to you?
那么，这对你意味着什么？
I don't know. I just thought it was funny.
不知道。我只是觉得它很有趣。
When Owen was little, I discovered I could get him to do anything by timing him. Go get your jacket, I'd say, or, clean up your toys, quick. I'll time you. He loved competing with himself and beating his old records, even if I just made up times. And it evolved into a huge, competitive, sports-loving thing that I still don't really understand or enjoy. That timing thing didn't work at all with Georgia. She'd just look up at me and say, what do you mean, time me? What for?
当欧文小的时候，我发现可以通过给他计时来让他做任何事。去拿你的夹克，我说，或者，快点把你的玩具收拾干净。我会为你计时。他喜欢和自己竞争，打破旧纪录，即使我只是胡乱编造时间。这演变成了一个巨大的、竞争性的、热爱运动的事情，我到现在还不真正理解或享受。那种计时方法在乔治亚身上一点都不管用。她只会抬头看着我说：你是什么意思，计时？为了什么？
The difference between him and Georgia in the talking department is huge. Georgia will come home from school and literally reenact her entire day so that she's telling me about it almost in real time, hour after hour. Owen, on the other hand, might tell me that his day was good, even if it was bad, but usually, he just shrugs and makes an "I don't know" kind of sound. And then he'll head down to the basement and play his guitar.
他在说话方面与乔治亚的差距巨大。乔治亚会放学回家，真的重演她的一整天，以至于她几乎是实时地、一小时一小时地告诉我。另一方面，欧文可能会告诉我他这一天过得不错，即使其实很糟糕，但通常他只是耸耸肩，发出一种“我不知道”的声音。然后他会去地下室弹吉他。
So some of your friends have girlfriends. And do you ever think that you'd like to have a girlfriend?
所以你的一些朋友有女朋友。你有没有想过也想有个女朋友？
[CHUCKLES] Yeah.
[笑声] 想过。
What do you think they think? How would they describe you to their friends, do you think?
你觉得她们怎么想？你觉得她们会怎么向朋友形容你？
Mm. I don't know.
嗯。不知道。
Do you think you do know, but you just don't really want to talk about it with me?
你觉得你知道，但只是不想和我谈论它？
I think that-- yeah, I think so.
我觉得——是的，我想是的。
I can dig it.
我明白了。
I've learned over time not to worry too much about his silence, although it used to drive me crazy. I wondered if maybe he'd turn out to be a psychopath, although I'm not sure why I associate evil with silence. Anyway, I'm getting better with it.
随着时间的推移，我已经学会了不要太担心他的沉默，尽管那曾经让我发疯。我怀疑他是否会成为一个心理变态，尽管我不确定为什么要把邪恶与沉默联系起来。无论如何，我对此处理得更好了。
Cassidy often reassures me by saying stuff like, it's a guy thing, or, he's a 15-year-old boy. What do you expect? He told me that when he was Owen's age, he sat in his bedroom by himself for hours on end, typing page after page of angry vitriol against the world on an old manual typewriter until his fingers bled. And he seems really happy now.
卡西迪常安慰我，说些像“这是男孩的事，”或“他是个15岁的男孩。你还指望什么？”之类的话。他告诉我，他像欧文那么大时，曾在卧室里独自坐几个小时，用旧手动打字机打出一页又一页对世界的愤怒抨击，直到手指流血。他现在看起来真的很幸福。
I realize my kids sound like boy and girl stereotypes. Owen is taciturn and into sports, and Georgia is chatty and prone to the occasional crying jag. But it really just is that way. I don't know why. It's not like we planned it. I don't want to think it's because he's a boy and she's a girl. But if it is, who cares?
我意识到我的孩子听起来像男孩和女孩的刻板印象。欧文沉默寡言，喜欢运动，而乔治亚健谈，偶尔会大哭一场。但事实确实如此。我不知道为什么。这不像我们计划好的。我不愿认为这是因为他是男孩，她是女孩。但如果是，谁在乎呢？
When Georgia was upset about something at school the other day and face down on the couch, he sat on the floor beside her and said, it's hard being a girl, isn't it? I'm not sure that it's any easier being a boy. And I don't know what he does exactly when he's sad, other than listening to music. Except for once, it's been years since I've seen him cry. I'd kill to read his notebook.
前几天乔治亚在学校因为某事感到不安，脸朝下趴在沙发上，他坐在她身边的地板上说：做女孩很难，对吧？我不确定做男孩会更容易。除了听音乐，我不知道他难过时具体做什么。除了一次，我已经好几年没见他哭了。我愿意杀人来读他的笔记。
Is there anything about girls that you envy?
关于女孩，有什么是你羡慕的吗？
Mm. No, nothing.
嗯。没有，什么都没有。
Nothing?
什么都没有？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
Well, what about their-- it seems-- their ability to talk about how they feel about things easier?
嗯，关于她们的——看起来——她们能更容易地谈论对事物的感受？
Sure, yeah.
当然，是的。
You envy that?
你羡慕那个？
I definitely envy that.
我绝对羡慕那个。
We were all pretty quiet as we drove up to Colorado Springs on our way to Denver. The sun was shining, but it was raining a bit. And we saw not one, not two, but three dead cows in fields, stiff, with their legs in the air, and it bothered us. After the third dead cow, I played my favorite song of the summer, Gillian Welch's "Elvis Presley Blues." It's a wistful song about the King as a 15-year-old boy, just starting out with a big rock and roll dream in a shirt his mother made. And it was kind of miraculous because Owen actually liked it, too.
我们在开车去科罗拉多斯普林斯前往丹佛的路上时，大家都很安静。阳光明媚，但下了一点雨。我们没看到一只，没两只，而是三只死牛躺在田里，僵硬着，腿朝天，这让我们很困扰。看到第三只死牛后，我放了我那个夏天最喜欢的歌，吉莉安·韦尔奇的《猫王蓝调》。那是一首关于国王15岁少年时的忧郁歌曲，刚开始有一个巨大的摇滚梦，穿着他妈妈做的衬衫。这简直是个奇迹，因为欧文竟然也喜欢它。
For me, it was a song about a boy becoming a man and leaving home, and it made me a little sad. I think Owen was probably hearing it as a song about a cool 15-year-old who was about to conquer the world. But really, I haven't got a clue how he heard the song or how it made him feel. All he said was that it had a decent pop sensibility. And then he was quiet.
对我来说，这是一首关于男孩成为男人并离开家的歌，它让我有点难过。我认为欧文可能把它当作一首关于一个酷酷的、即将征服世界的15岁少年的歌。但老实说，我根本不知道他是怎么听这首歌的，或者它让他有什么感觉。他只说这首歌有不错的流行感。然后他就安静了。
These days, the more I press him for information, the faster he shuts right down. The other day, I tried a new approach-- his. I was annoyed by a bunch of things, and rather than broadcast it all over the house, I sat on the couch and glared at the TV and sighed periodically.
这些天，我越是逼他提供信息，他关掉的速度就越快。前几天，我尝试了一种新方法——他的方法。我被很多事情弄得很烦，与其在家里大肆宣扬，我坐在沙发上盯着电视，偶尔叹叹气。
And strangely, Owen responded. He observed my weirdness for a while and then left. Then he came back and looked at me again and said one word, "Mom," but in such a nice way that I smiled and said, "Owen." And that was it. And then we sat there for a while, silently. I was surprised by how completely comfortable it felt. And then, finally, wordlessly, he got up and took his laundry upstairs.
奇怪的是，欧文回应了。他观察了一会儿我的古怪，然后离开了。然后他又回来看了我一眼，只说了一个词：“妈妈”，但以一种如此友好的方式，我笑了笑说：“欧文。”就是这样。然后我们坐在那里待了一会儿，沉默着。我惊讶地发现这种感觉是多么完全的舒适。最后，他一言不发地起身，把他的洗衣服拿到了楼上。
Miriam Toews is a writer in Winnipeg. She wrote The X Letters in one of our programs. Her latest book is called Swing Low.
米里亚姆·托斯是温尼伯的一位作家。她在我们的节目中写过《X信件》。她最新的书叫《轻摇》。
["ALMOST GROWN" BY CHUCK BERRY]
["Almost Grown", 查克·贝瑞演唱]
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine, senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Chris Neary. Special thanks today to El Jefe, to [? Buzzy ?] [? Goldstein, ?] to Robert Powell, to Jim Nelson at GQ, our Daniel Foster, Sarah Vowell, and David Rakoff, who I swear we will never mess with again.
好吧，我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我本人制作，温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩参与，高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。生产帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和克里斯·尼瑞。特别感谢今天的老板，给[？巴兹？][？戈尔茨坦，？]给罗伯特·鲍威尔，给《GQ》的吉姆·纳尔逊，我们的丹尼尔·福斯特、萨拉·沃威尔和大卫·拉科夫，我发誓我们再也不会惹他们了。
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, or visit our website, where you can also listen to our programs for free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life comes to you from the city of Chicago, Richard M. Daley, mayor. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who owns a very, very big radio. This is what he says about it.
要购买此节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380，或访问我们的网站，您也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目，thisamericanlife.org。本节目来自芝加哥市，市长理查德·M·戴利。《美国生活》由公共广播国际部发行。我们节目的资金来自WBEZ芝加哥的听众。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他拥有一台非常、非常大的收音机。这就是他关于它的话。
This big, shuddering, warm, inanimate object would just drive me crazy. It was very erotic to me.
这个巨大的、颤动的、温暖的、无生命的物体会让我发疯。它对我来说非常色情。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
["ALMOST GROWN" BY CHUCK BERRY]
["Almost Grown", 查克·贝瑞演唱]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际部。